la volta al món a peu
dia 291
no me n'ha enxampat
nit molt tranquil, a més
he dormit bastant bé
a pesar d'uns gossos
que no he parat d'abordar durant bastanta estona
sembla que aquí a la Xina
els gossos també estan igual
és el problema de tot el món
un problema mundial
de cor ja ha sortit el sol, nit poc freda també
són les 10 menys quart
que vindria a ser
vindria a ser, deixem calcular
les 6.45, perfecte
i doncs anem tirant
no porto ni una hora de caminada
ja he arribat a un dels llocs on
als voltants d'aquí tenia pensat acampar
i sort que no ho vaig fer
perquè a part que està molt concorregut
d'acord?
això és un parc natural
és una zona d'observació
d'ocells
són uns aigua moix aquí i hi ha ocells
i...
bueno, a mi em semblen uns aigua moix
molt normalets
és que de fet no sé si arriba aigua moix
sí que són
no sé si té
un interès tan especial
però bueno
estic mirant, eh?
si veig algun ocell us l'ensenyo, eh?
però de moment no veig res
a veure, l'entorn és maco
perquè tens les muntanyes de fons, no?
o la vall en si
bueno, no, està bé, està bé
que es protegeixin el seu
aquí hi ha
aquí hi ha alguna cosa
potser puc halar alguna cosa, tu
bueno, estic a la zona aquí
on la gent fa més fotos
jo pel que he vist a internet
als xinesos els encanta molt el postureig
els encanta fer-se fotos
i tot el tema de xarxes socials
a nosaltres també, eh?
però sí, sí, ha arribat aquí
amb força aquest tema
no sé si hi haurà algun ocell
però bueno, no hi ha gaire botigues
no hi ha cap botiga de menjar
són tot botigues de souvenirs
i ens és la càmera ara
per dir-vos que
estic veient postals
estic veient postals, sí senyor
buà
molaria molt una postal de la Xina, no?
els que esteu apuntats a l'aixeta
molaria moltíssim
jo és que pensava en aquesta zona
ja us ho vaig dir l'altre dia
que no seria turística
i no trobaria cap postal
doncs sí, sí, sí
altres que encara no sé si n'hi haurà
però si n'hi ha aquí
potser la compro aquí
vaig a preguntar el preu i tal
home, em solucionaria bastant la papereta
pel tema que us vaig dir que a Pakistan
seria una mica difícil de trobar-la
fins que no arribés a la capital i tal
així em solucionaria la papereta, sí
home, jo suposo que des de la Xina
es poden enviar postals a Europa, no?
ara ho investigaré per internet
bueno, per si algú no sap
de què estic parlant
estic donant d'alta a l'aixeta
que és una plataforma de micromecenatge
a la qual, si no és una aportació mensual
doncs també hi ha una postal cada mes
ara mateix hi ha gairebé
600 persones apuntades
550 i pico, 660 i pico
i sí, sí
hauré de comprar unes 600 postals
tens l'enllaç a la descripció
i també a la xarxa
a la meva web
laboltamonapeu.cat
doncs ja les tinc
600 postals
hòstia, hauré d'haver agafat el rebut
bueno, us ensenyo la captura de l'IPEI
1.800 gens
costava 3 gens la postal
3 gens són
40 cèntims
40 cèntims és tirant a
tirant a mig alt
comparat amb el que he pagat a altres països
i no hi ha hagut manera de regatejar
no, els xinesos són
estrictes i no hi havia manera
de fer descompte
a veure, jo després he mirat
quant costa la postal internacional
i són 6 gens
60 cèntims costa enviar la postal
a internacional
és molt poc
és molt menys que a Uzbekistan fins i tot
que era el lloc més barat
per tant he dit, bueno, llavors em compensa
encara que la postal sigui una mica cara
perquè després l'enviament serà barat
això sí, he preguntat on enviar-la
jo sé que hi ha una oficina de correus a Trash Congar
però m'han dit que allà
molt probablement no la puc enviar des d'allà
perquè és una zona fronterera
m'estranyen molt
m'han dit que potser he d'anar fins a Kashgar
bueno
com ja us vaig dir ahir
potser he d'anar fins a Kashgar igualment
perquè m'avorreixo Trash Congar i per mirar altres coses
perquè he d'esperar el visat de la Pakistana
llavors ja ho veurem
m'estranyaria molt que no l'enviessin des d'allà
però bueno, ok
ah, quins dissenys he agafat
doncs he agafat un disseny, la majoria
més de 500 postals són del mateix disseny
que és la frontera entre Pakistan i Xina
m'ha semblat una cosa bastant icònica
a part de que mola la postal
m'ha semblat bastant icònic perquè si tot va bé
creuaré aquesta frontera, la frontera més alta del món
és un moment especial de la volta al món a peu
i hauré d'estar bé reflectint-me en la postal
i després 80 que em quedaven
les he agafat d'altres coses, també maques
postals de les muntanyes d'aquí
i de llocs d'aquí
doncs bastant macos
he de dir que les postals de Xina
són de les més maques
de totes les que he agafat fins ara, de la volta al món a peu
les de Croàcia no estaven malament
tampoc, però les de la Xina xules
molt bé, tu, ara el problema és que he de carregar això
durant 20 quilòmetres
i pesa bastant
mireu com mola aquest mapa esquemàtic
aquí és cap a Kashgar
això és Tajikistan
és a dir, aquí Kulma Pass
aquí baixant és per on estem nosaltres
per aquí més o menys
això és
Trash Kongar perquè hi ha
uns aiguamois i hi ha una fortalesa que veurem
i si vas cap a baix, aquí
te'n vas cap a Afghanistan
i aquí
la frontera amb Pakistan que és el que surt a la postal
aquest edifici mític
Pakistan
està guai
bueno, segueixo caminant, ara la carretera passa
al costat d'aquests desmunts
i el voral
és bastant estret
s'haurà d'anar
bastant en compte
és un tram de
no sé, uns
5-7 quilòmetres, no sé si tota l'estona
serà així
ja estic sortint de la zona aquesta del Congost
i aquí davant veig el que sembla
un peatge, no sabia que hi havia peatges a Xina
però no, no, no és un peatge
he traduït aquest senyal d'aquí
i posa control policial
a 200 metres
a l'antiu, sisplau
llavors, bueno, ara vaig a deixar de gravar
i res, control policial
passaport
i aquestes coses
control de passaport i ja està
molt bé tu
bueno, 13 quilòmetres
fins al destí
us en recordeu del repte
de Tajikistan?
no el vaig complir, el tema aquell de les plagues d'autobús
en vaig trobar 5 en dos dies
i després ja està
repte de Xina
Xina serà molt curt
un repte que sembla fàcil però potser no ho és
intentar menjar
un rollito de primavera
i ho dic en castellà
perquè jo de petit
tothom, jo crec
què sabíem de Xina, no sabíem res de Xina
que érem molta gent
que teníem la cara així
i el menjar xinès que teníem als restaurants xinesos
crec que és un repte perquè en aquesta zona de la Xina
doncs feien altres tipus de menjar
els menjars iogurts, uigurs, etc.
i això és un repte perquè en aquesta zona de la Xina feien altres tipus de menjar
i bueno, coses del Pamir
perquè encara estem al Pamir geogràficament
llavors jo no sé si trobarem el típic menjar xinès xinès
i de fet alguns en direu
home, Enric
això del rollito de primavera és una cosa que van crear
els xinesos que van venir a Occident
per adaptar-se als paladars nostres
doncs mira, encara més motiu
perquè sigui un repte
trobar un rollito de primavera
bueno, 10 minuts després
de passar el control aquest de
dels polis
em para un cotxe de policia
una altra vegada
i em fan apropar-me
i treuen el seu traductor
això he de dir que
molt bé, que sàpiguen fer salir el traductor
bé, el seu traductor
i que saps, guai, vale
fan salir el seu traductor
i em comencen
a parlar i tradueix directament ja
a l'espanyol
o sigui, ja sabien qui era
entenc que des del control policial aquest
han trucat a la policia del comtat
i la policia ha vingut aquí
i ja sabien que
hi havia algú amb passaport espanyol aquí
i ja sabien que hi havia algú amb passaport espanyol aquí
total, què m'han dit?
bé, som la policia d'aquest comtat
i ara
era algo així com que
estàs al nostre càrrec
o ara nosaltres som els encarregats de tu
o...
bé, no exactament així però una cosa així
cosa que per mi és un eufemisme de
xaval, sabem qui ets
sabem on estàs i estàs controladíssim
i amb un somriure
i després
d'on venia?
Tajikistan, i els he dit on anava
Pakistan, bla, bla, bla
els he dit, sort que els he dit
els he dit que potser me'n vaig a
un o dos dies a
això a Kashgar i després torno
sí
sí, sí
bla, vosaltres creieu que
he controlat les meves xarxes socials?
creieu que
les miren?
no ho sé
però, ostres
no m'he sentit tan vigilat a la meva vida
hi ha molt profits
i healthcare
com Fortune...
i davant d'això,
uff, i de cap asp Fantastia
m'augur de moltíssim
i perro
Get Kabul
tot és building
Tstrom
Model
Mira, he trobat el lloc on fan els jocs de jics, pamirs.
Hem vist alguna imatge, tant a les postals com aquí,
que hi havia imatges que fan com una espècie d'esport amb llacs,
i no sé molt bé què fan.
Llacs, vull dir l'animal aquest, perquè hi ha llacs aquí.
No sé si hi ha unes grades,
hi ha aquí un camp ben gran per practicar aquest esport,
que no tinc ni idea de què va.
Però moleria, potser aquest finde fan alguna cosa aquí.
Investigarem.
Doncs ja he arribat, estem a les afores,
a punt d'entrar ja, o ja entrant a Tax Congar,
he dit aquest nom 40.000 vegades ja.
Ui, m'he quedat aquí sense sortida.
Bueno.
Doncs sí, sí, sí, sí, molt guai.
Bueno, he reservat ja l'hotel, dos nits he reservat,
i mínim dos nits, després ja ho veurem.
I l'hotel està aquí a prop, aquí a l'entrada.
Bueno, després us ho ensenyaré al centre de la ciutat
i altres coses, si és que baixo.
Però abans de tot, abans de pujar a l'hotel i tot,
m'agradaria menjar alguna cosa.
Sí, sí, sí.
Aquí estic una mica venut, aquí a Xina,
perquè el Google Maps,
té algunes coses, especialment aquí,
que és una zona frontalera,
és una zona bastant de pas de turisme,
però no té tots els restaurants, ni de conya.
Jo m'hi guio bastants per les ressenyes,
i no hi ha ressenyes ni res.
Jo sé que hi ha el Google Maps xinès,
que es diu AMaps, crec.
Però és igual, no me'l descarregaré, saps?
De moment.
Confiaré una mica en la pinta del restaurant,
aquest té bona pinta.
I...
Què em ve de gust? No ho sé.
Bé, tu, ara decideixo, hi ha bastanta cosa que hi ha de menjar.
Doncs he entrat al primer restaurant que m'ha fet bona pinta,
i bé, allò que he dit que potser em costaria trobar menjar xinès xinès,
ho retiro, perquè tots els restaurants d'aquí són xinesos.
El que passa és que hi havia molts de hot pot,
molts de barbacoa, d'aquestes i aquests a la taula,
i ara mateix una cosa tan alvorada no em venia de gust.
Aquest, en canvi, semblava a mi el senzill,
i bé, és un restaurant en el qual tu tens aquesta nevera,
i a la nevera hi ha aquests pinxos, aquestes butxetes.
I tu selecciones les que vols.
N'hi ha de tot tipus, n'hi ha de verdures, n'hi ha de bolets,
carn, marisc, bé, peix, el que sigui.
I bé, doncs tenen el preu,
i després ells, tu et posen a la fregidora aquesta,
bé, elles, que són dues dones,
a la fregidora aquesta, te la fregeixen,
i aquí ho tenim.
Aquí ho tenim. No sé si m'ha demanat molt poc.
No sé si... Mira, què he demanat? Mira.
Pa.
Això és com una verdura amb bolcallada, no sé què.
Això no tinc ni idea del que és.
Ni tinc ni idea del que és.
Aquestes dues són d'algun tipus de carn.
Aquestes boles no sé de què són.
Crec que deu ser alguna cosa de peix.
I això diria que és tofu. A mi m'agrada el tofu.
No sé què fan.
I aquestes de bolets amb bolcallada amb pernil.
Bueno, a mi m'ha preguntat, m'ha preguntat,
com ho vols? Sense picant, amb una mica de picant,
o picant mitjà?
Deia picant mitjà, que era la versió més alta que m'ha dit.
Potser m'he equivocat, ara us ho diré.
I després de beure, això.
Això l'he preguntat a la IA què és.
I m'ha dit que és una beguda d'origen eslau,
de russa i d'ucraïna,
que, bueno, van popularitzar aquí els russos i els uigurs,
que ho van portar, importar des d'aquella zona,
de russa i d'ucraïna.
I, bueno, és una beguda feta així, amb mel,
fermentada,
i és molt típica d'aquí, d'aquesta zona de Xinjiang.
I l'he provat, i té sabor...
És una mescla.
Entre mel i cervesa.
Té molt poca graduació,
tipus 0,3 graus,
segons l'IA.
No seria la meva cosa preferida,
perquè és un pèl massa dolç pel meu gust.
Clar, jo ara veig això
i m'espero a beure una cervesa amb aquest color.
I no.
Però no està mal, eh, tampoc? No està mal.
Bueno, ho vaig a menjar i a dir-vos...
Bueno, anem a provar-ho, a veure si m'he passat de picant.
Puc tolerar-ho, però una mica menys picant
m'agradaria més.
Aquest picant, a part del picant, té sabor
i també és un pèl dolcet.
A la xineta els hi ha aquest tipus de sabors, ja està.
Jo de mesclar dolç i salat no sóc massa, però bueno.
No, però està bé, està bé.
Vinga, vaig a dinar.
Doncs m'he quedat prou bé, eh?
Estava prou bo.
Hi havia alguns que tenien un sabor així com a...
bola de marisc, bola de peix...
No m'ha acabat d'agradar, però la resta bastant bons.
Especialment els de verdura, he de dir.
I els bolets aquests raros que tenen aquí.
Sabeu com m'ha costat?
Després, a part de tot això, m'he demanat també un altre Sprite
perquè m'estava cremant la llengua del picant.
5 euros.
Tot 5 euros.
I el postre no pot fallar ara.
Un geladet.
Ben bo, té bona pinta.
Amb les muntanyes de fons, 26 cèntims, tu.
Anem a provar-lo?
Mmm.
És el típic gelat així molt industrial de...
de...
però molt bé, molt bo i molta quantitat, eh?
Crec que menjaré bé aquí, eh?
Crec que tornaré a guanyar el pes que he perdut a Tajikistan.
Ben primat a Tajikistan, no sé si ho havíeu notat, però...
ara el recuperaré, segur.
Doncs no està gens malament, no?, l'habitació.
Llit doble, cosa que no necessito.
Però diria que en tota la ciutat no hi havia cap habitació individual pura.
Bueno, evidentment aquesta no és la més barata de la ciutat, no.
Però és que els preus són bons, llavors he decidit agafar una així una mica més...
més guai, perquè, ostres, ara feia molt temps que no hagués sigut...
que no estava a un hotel allò
com Déu mana, eh? Des d'aquí el dia que vaig
arribar a la frontera amb l'Afganistan
de Tajikistan, que no estava
a un hotel guai, m'ha costat 50 euros dos nits
per tant, 25 euros la nit
Ostres, està superbé
A veure, l'he agafat aquesta
en comptes d'altres perquè té una cadira
i una espècie d'escriptori aquí
i aquí podré escriure les postals
és bastant important tenir una taula bé perquè si no
em fan molt mal les cervicals si d'escriure
el llit o on sigui
Doncs això, 50 euros, molt bé
Té una cosa
curiosa aquesta habitació i altres
que he vist a Taj Kongar
sempre ho dic malament, que és una
aparell per oxigen
Clar, estem alts
3.000 metres diria
i si tu vens
amb avió des d'aquí
des de poca altitud
llavors et pot donar el mal d'altura
si no estàs aclimatat, també depèn de la gent
hi ha gent que li dona, gent que no
i sí, sí, molts hotels d'aquí tenen
aquest dispensador d'oxigen
per evitar els problemes
del mal d'altura, és fort
no ho havia vist mai
estem a... imagina't trobar-te això al Pamir
saps? No, ni de conya
estem als, a veure si ho veig
sí, sí, sí, 3.100
més o menys, em noto molt menys
ofegat, recordo estar al Pamir
i pensant, buah, necessito
un hotel i descansar
3 o 4 dies perquè
estic fatal i
ara sí, em ve de gust el descans a un hotel bé
però no
no sé jo que hagi arribat i, oh, saps
bueno, en fi
què més té aquest hotel?
les cortines
té un botó aquí al costat del llit que tu apretes
i les cortines s'obren o es tanquen
genial, ja, ja
espectacular
bueno, també té aigua
està molt bé, però hi ha una cosa
que és un problema, que és un gran problema
que és l'endoll
tots els endolls
cap endoll s'adapta als meus
connectors, a la Guesso els que vaig
estar el primer dia a la Xina
l'endoll, jo podria endollar les meves coses
suposo que com era un lloc més
internacional, no ho sé, però, home, aquí
que és un lloc de pas de gent
haurien de tenir com a mínim l'opció
a la recepció que he anat a preguntar
que em donessin un adaptador
i no, no, no
i això no ho tenia previst, perquè clar, jo al principi
quan vaig començar a planejar l'aventura
no tenia previst venir a la Xina
a veure, per sort
hi ha algun dels connectors aquests
que tenen entrada USB A
jo tinc un cable USB A
que suposo que carregarà molt lent
però crec que faré servir això, aniré carregant
les bateries i així carregaré
perquè no vull comprar un adaptador
un adaptador per què? Per tres dies?
Una setmana que estaré aquí? No ho sé, no
crec que no val la pena
sí, bueno, avui
vint i pico quilòmetres
no sé quant
de refrescos dos
bueno, això que he vist que m'he pres
i m'he gastat
de moment
doncs, a veure
50 euros de l'hotel aquest, dos nits
5 euros del dinar
i 20 i pico cèntims
del gelat aquest, bueno, suposo que en gastaré
més el proper dia, ja us ho dic
d'acord, i no he parlat amb ningú
anem a fer una foguera
ara feia temps que no
fèiem, a veure, la Mercè pregunta
canvi de bambes a la Xina, com ho has
previst? Les bambes estan
bastant destrossades
us recordo que les vaig comprar a Georgia
a l'últim dia de Georgia
per tant, podrien
i que vaig comenar el primer dia amb elles
a Tajikistan, i porten
1.200 quilòmetres, potser una mica més
potser 1.300
sí, és bastant, però les Icebook
les vaig durar
més de 2.000 quilòmetres
algun parell, i l'àper, la part de dalt
estava perfecta, us recordeu? L'únic que fallava
era la sola, que evidentment tenia un desgast
les hookah no, estan molt
destrossades ja de la part de dalt, bueno, molt no
però bastant
especialment el que enganxa la sola
amb la part de dalt
potser perquè hi ha de segona mà
o potser perquè tenen poca durabilitat, no ho sé
encara puc caminar amb elles
però convendria un canvi, sí, sí, sí
però aquí a la Xina
malauradament no serà possible
crec, perquè pel que m'han dit
el meu número no el fan
a la Xina, directament no el fan
o sigui, el meu número del 46
directament no el puc ni comprar
si anés a
Kashgar ja miraria
a veure si hi ha l'opció
podries comprar-ho per internet, Enric, potser
si ja tenen el teu número
ostres, ara posar-me a comprar coses per internet a la Xina
pfff, quin desgavell, no?
no sé si deu ser fàcil, no ho sé
la meva idea seria continuar caminant
i a Pakistan comprar-les
a Pakistan trobaré vames de qualitat
especialment al nord
aquesta zona
mmm, també ho dubto
però no ho sé, però
aquí a la Xina segurament no, no sigui possible
En Susumant pregunta si no he vist
pics de 3.000 metres, de 7.000 metres
a la zona del Pamir Tajik
doncs...
no, no, no, no els he vist en principi
el pic Lenin
que jo sàpiga
està a la frontera amb Kirguistán
i per tant jo no he anat tan allà
per tant no he vist muntanyes de 7.000 metres, no
i per últim, en Tomeu Calafat
excompany de la Uni
Grande
pregunta pel les pulsacions per minut
del rellotge
aquest rellotge i tots els rellotges
et marquen la pulsació per minut
mentre estàs fent un exercici
jo això mai ho miro, no m'interessa gaire
però bueno, ja per aquesta pregunta
doncs
ho he mirat
i aquesta seria una captura de pantalla
d'una etapa del Pamir molt plana
i fica això
crec que fica de mitja, 98 era
i de màxima 100 i pico
bueno, ho teniu aquí
i ho he comparat amb una etapa
l'etapa crec que era la etapa 6
o etapa 8 a França
és a dir, la primera
la primera setmana quan estava igual
i una etapa també molt plana
i excepte la part final que puja molt
i puja més de 150 pulsacions
la resta també crec que
la mitjana és similar, 90 i pico
sincerament jo no en sé
gaire d'això de pulsacions
per tant si teniu curiositat podeu anar al meu estraba
i totes les meves etapes
tenen allà les pulsacions
i podeu mirar, i si em feu l'estudi
vosaltres ja em digueu si he millorat
capacitat pulmular o no
la teoria diria
que potser he millorat una mica
però no crec que gaire
perquè he caminat molt molt molt
en pla, aquí a Tajikistan
m'he exigit més
he fet una mica més d'esnivell alguns dies
tampoc tant, però sobretot pel tema
de caminar en altura
no sé, quan arribi
a les cotes baixes de Pakistan potser em noto
molt més fort perquè he estat aquí una setmana climatat
no ho sé
també influeix molt el pes de la motxilla
influeix molt la calor que faci
però bueno
jo crec que aquests dies ha fet similar calor a l'hivern
passat perquè no
feia calor, molt bé
doncs això és tot, he decidit que el vídeo s'acaba aquí
i demà
que per vosaltres és dissabte
doncs no hi haurà vídeo
i el diumenge faré un vídeo
doncs no ho sé
explicant una mica aquí
que hi ha
si faig alguna mica de turisme
o el que sigui
un bloc així una mica random
també vull fer un directe aquí a la Xina
d'acord? però encara no he decidit
quan, potser el diumenge de fet seria
una bona idea
en qualsevol cas esteu atents al meu instagram
estigueu atents al meu instagram i estigueu atents
també al meu youtube
que quan apareixi un directe sempre el poso en un dia
d'antelació i podeu veure el compte enrere
i tal
d'acord senyors i senyores
vinga, bona
tarda